hey you
are finally awake even if you've never
played skyrim there's a strong chance
you still know this intro hey you
are finally awake since its release a
decade ago this intro has become ever
iconic but it almost didn't happen that
way in fact during its development just
about everything was trying to stop this
opening from happening especially one
bug in particular that derailed the
entire thing and by bug i mean like a
literal bug in fact most specifically
a beam
it starts vibrating like this wait what
what's happening and then it just goes
boom
up into the sky like what oh come on
what now
that is nate percupine the senior world
artist on skyrim and while brings loads
of joy and nostalgia for me and many
others to see that intro for nate
it's a bit of a touchy subject how many
times do you think you've seen
the intro of skyrim
yeah
easily hundreds it's like almost 10
years later now
and i still kind of cringe at the idea
of watching it again during skyrim's
development nate was a part of a team
that meet weekly to watch this intro
over and over again polishing it up and
making sure the game's first big moment
ran perfectly
[Music]
obviously it was definitely not perfect
for a long time because that card
it's not just like a predetermined path
but it's actually simulated so that
would mean that that cart would break
constantly a lot of people who were not
involved would go in and like oh i'm
going to adjust the road a little bit
and make it look a little bit bumpier
but that bumpiness would then cause it
to flip the card over so one time it's
going that path is totally smooth now we
thought it was fine
it's going down in the meeting again and
then
it starts vibrating like this
wait what what's happening and then it
just goes boom
up into the sky like what oh come on
what now so we're like okay restart it
see what's going on
it goes fine nothing happens
again nothing happens
but then
you know like one out of 20 times or
something like that it would just freak
out
[Music]
turns out there was a few things getting
in the way first separate from nate's
team there was a department dedicated to
developing bugs and critters in the game
which was populating the world alongside
other teams but within that team they
were dealing with a problem of their own
bees are a lootable item in skyrim used
to make stuff like potions
but there was another bug and i mean
like an actual bug like a game bug this
time where you couldn't loot the b
preventing the player from making those
certain potions so to fix that someone
went and changed the collision of the b
which determines how it interacts with
the rest of the world and while
collision and games can be
complicated there's all these different
situations where you need things to
behave differently like even stairs
they're made up of multiple kinds of
collision because you want the person to
like your camera to go up smoothly but
then you want feet to actually like
touch every single stair so there's like
these multiple layers of it there's
other kinds of collision where it like
blocks your movement but you can shoot
stuff through it
so it's like a pretty long list of like
10 or 15 types so you always have to
make sure you put the right one on and
one of those many types of collision was
incorrectly given to
this bee one is like
for flowers and stuff like that where
you can like run right through them but
you can pick it up
and the other is like bottles and things
that can collide but bottles when they
get hit by something it gets knocked
over it has physics but
ai like that
if you push it it's not going to do
anything unless it's something like you
know foos rhoda telling it to actually
stop what you're doing like fly off a
cliff
and that's the thing unlike other
objects like flowers bottles or even the
cart the bee has intelligence it's a
thing that moves and lives independently
therefore the same principles that apply
to stuff like flowers and bottles and
all that jazz don't apply to the bee so
that means it's like this immovable box
like nothing will push it but that cart
is coming
and it also wants to go this way so it
wants to go this way and the bee is just
minding its own damn business
and so the only way for this to sort of
resolve with physics as it continues to
try and push further and further with
that card because it thinks it's further
it just kind of vibrates and well it has
to go up that's the only way and so and
then
rockets up into the sky that's what
ended up breaking the whole game was
like a literal bug caused the bug
and skyrim would break all the time in
all sorts of ways like that oh it sure
does even to this day even the card
scene is still a little rocky uh which i
could tell you firsthand from trying to
capture it for this very video
[Music]
no this can't be happening this isn't
happening while all of skyrim's problems
haven't been fixed the b culprit had
been found by qa and squashed
[Music]
sort of
because the b can actually still push
you around and i had no idea just look
at this dude get it all up in lizard
wizard's face
[Music]
now even despite all of skyrim's
existing bugs i have still put hundreds
of hours into that game i'd even go so
far to say that i think they've even
grown infinity towards that game's
jankiness like to me it's kind of become
a defining characteristic of the game
experience like a mole or a blemish that
you just kind of accepted as a beauty
mark it doesn't really ruin the game for
me except that be
but really it's incredible to think back
on 10 years of this game and kind of see
how it stepped above its wonkiness and
not only just become a defining part of
my gaming identity but also kind of set
the path for games going forward like
we're now coming on a decade
of its existence and not including the
time it took to develop
what is that like my curiosity it had a
great impact on game so it's clear to me
that like it changed the course of games
in a lot of ways like i talked to people
that worked on like the witcher and
stuff and they were big fans of the game
you can see the influences there so it's
fun to see that impact because i always
liked
personally building games that felt more
like a world and not just a game and i
think a lot of things have shifted
towards that more and it sounds really
obvious now saying 10 years later but
at the time most games were not like
that and of course the memes because
there's always memes the meme stuff
definitely caught us off guard so it was
pretty funny to see the random things
that people would pick up on in the
games like the arrow and the knee thing
is
obviously my favorite because it's just
so dumb and nobody thought twice about
it even though we like played hundreds
of hours you just kind of like
tune it out
so you don't even pick up that okay like
it's kind of a weird thing to say not
expecting people years later to get like
tattoos of arrows on their knees and
stuff i'm still playing skyrim to this
day uh so if that means anything like
from from its launch even on the ps3 now
to mostly have my nintendo switch even
10 years later this game remains like
comfort food to me it's like it's the
thing i play in between other games or
the thing that's permanently on my
nintendo switch when i go on a flight or
like even the bedside nightcap to like
drift off to
a lot of bugs remain in the game but its
environment tone and magical world has
endured and as a place i revisit often
even if just for a walk
as for its opening every time i see it i
know it means the beginning of a new
adventure through northern tamriel
thankfully for nate well he doesn't have
to look at that intro anymore because
he's moved on to pursue game development
as a solo indie dev instead i think
every game to do blooper reel i think
would be the best thing ever i'm keeping
videos on my current game of terrible
bloopers i just know that every time i
see it again or every time i find myself
taking a walk outside the ruins of
helgen that not only will i think about
the developers who had to sit through it
hundreds of times but that almost didn't
happen entirely because
of a b
hey you
you're finally awake
you were trying to cross the border
right
walk right into that imperial ambush
same as us and that thief over there
damn you stormcloaks